the president of the united states is
supposed to be our representative to the
world
yet joe biden spends most of his time
bad mouthing us
and of course highlighting only the
darkest periods of our history
as he did today in tulsa the flames from
those burning crosses
torched every region every region of the
country
millions of white americans belonged to
the klan
and they weren't even embarrassed by it
they were proud of it
and that hate became
embedded systematically and systemically
in our laws and our culture
of course what he conveniently left out
of his storytelling is that those kkk
members were almost all democrats
and in fact he was buddies with some of
the more prominent southern senators who
rose to
fame and the segregationist south and he
even co-sponsored
anti-bussing legislation with senator
strom thurman and jesse helms
biden didn't simply compromise with
segregationists
he also led the charge on an issue that
kept black
students away from the classrooms of
white students but of course the same
frauds who ignore the full arc of
american history
stepped up to whitewash biden's true
views
and just like that the same man who was
pals with a former exalted cyclops of
the kkk senator robert byrd
was today indicting the country we love
what happened in greenwood was an act of
hate and domestic terrorism
with the through line that exists today
still
just close your eyes remember what you
saw in charlottesville
four years ago on television neo-nazis
white supremacist the kkk
coming out of those fields at night
virginia with lighted torches
the veins bulging on their as they were
screaming remember just close your eyes
and picture what it was
well or we could close our eyes and
pretend he's not president
but notice again what biden leaves out
nothing about the violence of last
summer that resulted in death and
destruction
and millions in lost income nothing
about the violent crime currently
plaguing american cities
which is by by the way
disproportionately committed uh
against minority minorities by
minorities and nothing about
how americans especially the
disadvantaged are being
targeted by drug cartels who are rushing
the border that biden and his cronies
are leaving wide open the fact is
not only do democrats have no solutions
for what currently ails america
their policies are making it all worse
open borders critical race theory
defunding the police their coddling of
antifa and blm
this all promotes the opposite of unity
and
healing and this is how their radical
base likes it though right
now remember their goal is a full-on
revolution against the american system
so their playbook is to keep smearing
america 75 million people voted for
trump
so of course they're the enemy and you
smear american history hoping that
this is all young people especially
black americans know
democrats sure don't want voters to see
the plain fact that
states like florida are getting more
prosperous
while states like california so woke
they are
are suffocating so why are democrats
relitigating the past or selectively
highlighting events
now one thing's for darn sure it's not
because they care
about black people it's simply about
power
and the next election it's patently
obvious that biden pelosi schumer
they refuse to offer minority voters
actual policies
that will make them better off a tight
border
common sense energy policy a robust
support for law and order
the only way that democrats can keep
winning elections
is by terrorizing black americans into
believing that half the country hates
them
and that they can't succeed under our
system as it currently is
this is sick and it's just setting up
millions of young men and women for
failure
now imagine biden's thinking about close
your eyes and imagine close your eyes
and imagine thinking that your entire
future
rises or falls on whether the government
gives you a check for past wrongdoing
democrats know they're not going to
deliver on rep reparations anyway
but they cynically dangle the
possibility
it's cruel and it's conniving
it's an ongoing race and switch look we
renamed
a street after black lives matter we
renamed this school after george floyd
we're funneling billions to historically
black colleges never mind that donald
trump's policies
increased african american incomes did
criminal justice reform
produce low record low unemployment
opportunity zones of course got
permanent funding for historically black
colleges never got any credit for that
for democrats it's not about dividing
people among
class class lines that's what the
marxists and the communists do but this
is among racial lines
more racial hatred and more racial
division
is the only way they can stay in power
terrorism for white supremacy is the
most lethal
threat to the homeland today not isis
not al-qaeda white supremacists
you can't govern a country you hate that
much you can only occupy
it and that's what biden and his party
are doing now
while we stumbled and committed grave
injustices along the way
that should not erase how far america
has come
but the blm is they don't spend a lot of
time on how we freed europe and world
war
ii or how american bravery innovation
and generosity has lifted hundreds of
millions of people out of poverty
because when you see the iwo jima
memorial
they want you to think racism
when you hear the star-spangled banner
they want you to think oppression and
when you see police officers
helping a homeless person they want you
to think
white supremacy
now as upsetting as the democrats hate
america ethos is
i'm telling you tonight it is not going
to work
most of the racial arsonists you see on
tv now
will be exposed as grifters tomorrow
blm is losing leaders faster than don
lemon's losing viewers
the innate goodness of the american
people the ongoing sacrifice of citizens
from
all backgrounds all races the wonders of
our unique
journey as a country none of that should
ever be minimized
the united states became the envy of the
world not by
constant self-loathing but by a
dedication to first principles
and i was thinking about this today i
don't think any president in the past
century not
fdr not jfk not truman
not clinton not even obama dedicated
himself
to turning african-americans against
their own country
but that is literally that's joe biden's
favorite word literally
all this president through his puppet
masters is doing
what they should be telling all of our
youth is that the only way to succeed in
america
is through diligence and self-discipline
instead they drone on about trump's big
lie while they perpetrate
the biggest fraud out there that america
was
founded on racism and is racist
this is a very dangerous game that biden
is playing
and we will not let him win hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else